euh bah oui c'est Brigitte bardau elle a
poussé un coup de gueule euh Brigitte
bardau il y a eu des SMS aussi divulgué
on va faire le point sur l'affaire Delon
qui rebondit tous les jours c'est Gilles
verdz qui a travaillé contrairement à
Jean-Michel mer aujourd'hui des messages
échang entre Anouka et Antoni Delon au
sujet de la santé de leurs père ont été
dévoilés Gilles c'est ça on va les
regarder après mais racontez-nous un
petit peu où on en est absolument des
messages qui datent de juillet 2023 et
qui montrent que déjà à cette époque-
làà anoska se préoccupait de l'arrêt des
soins qu'Antony semble préconiser et
elle elle elle ne veut absolument pas
arrêter le traitement elle dit on
n'arrête pas comme ça on n'arrête pas
contre la vie médicale parce que les
médecins Suisse veulent absolument que
le traitement perdure et visiblement les
deux garçons voulaient l'arrêter donc
ces SMS montrent que ça fait plusieurs
mois déjà canouka craint qu'alindelon
souffre d'un arrêt du traitement Suisse
voilà alors on va voir les messages
TikTok qui ont été échangés et après il
y a Brigitte bardau aussi qui a réagi
vous allez nous dire onù dans est
l'affaire aussi euh aujourd'hui parce
que c'est vrai que ça bouge tous les
jours c'est parti tous les jours nous
avons eu accès à certains des textau que
les trois enfants s'échangent concernant
la santé de leur père en voici une
retranscription son organisme est usé le
traitement le tue à petit feu pour lui
redonner un peu de force il faut
l'arrêter c'est une décision à prendre à
trois certes difficile il faut être
conscient que qu'on continue ou arrête
le traitement s'il lui arrive quelque
chose ce sera de notre faute ça l'épuise
c'est du poison ça lui bousie le système
on narrête pas comme ça contre avis
médical j'apprécierai qu'on m'écoute
là-dessus c'est pas un doliprane qu'on
arrête comme ça je viens de l'avoir
hôtel il veut pas arrêter les
médicaments et mourir non il a dit qu'il
voulait mourir c'est incroyable on
comprend mieux ouais on comprend mieux
maintenant pourquoi la guerre est totale
entre dans la fraterie parce que ça date
de plusieurs mois et on comprend mieux
aussi ce que nous révélions hier
c'estàdire que le procureur de Montargis
a mandaté un médecin pour faire une
expertise d'Alain Delon enfin on saura
dans quel état il est et s'il faut qu'il
reprenne son traitement donc s'il faut
qu'il aille en Suisse par ce que son
médecin depuis 15 ans et toute l'équipe
médicale à Genève veulent absolument
alors canouchka reproche au frères de
faire traiter Alain Delon par un
naturopathe une naturopathe voilà et d'ù
les là ça donne plutôt raison à nka de
absolument c'est-à-dire qu'il a besoin
de ce traitement visiblement quoi on
peut pas lui donner des jus de fruits
comme le préconise Anthony ça ne va pas
du tout ais mais c'est vrai que bah oui
le traitement absolument c'est aussi
toute la question de l'acharnement
thérapeutique est-ce qu'il faut
absolument maintenir quelqu'un en vie
quand tu vois qu'il est au seuil de sa
fille sa fille c'est normal qu'elle
veille le maintenir en ça ne peut que
lui donner raison lui le veut aussi le
signalement que nous avons révélé c'est
l'avocat d'Alain Delon qui avait donné
son consentement son avocat j'ai vérifié
à chaque fois ils obtienent non non mais
ils obtiennent le consentement c'est lui
qui veut aussi continuer ce traitement
bah bien sûr donc c'est c'est c'est quoi
là là ces éléments ils sont quand même
pour moi l'ensemble des éléments récents
sont à charge contre les deux frères
voilà je pense que l'expertise médicale
va prouver qu'il faut que le protocole
qui avait été élaboré en Suisse et que
suit Alain Delon pour une pathologie
très lourde très très lourde il a besoin
de ses soins voilà c'est pas à base de
jus de fruits qu'on soigne àin Delon
aujourd'hui voilà il y a Brigitte bardau
qui a réagi alors Brigit bardau on va
rappeler c'est une grande actrice aussi
oui grande actrice connais bien alin
Delon alors ils sont amis ils ont
toujours nié toute relation autre
camicale sentimentale ou amoureuse ce
que j'ai fait avec Daniel Mor également
absolument donc ils sont rencontrés en
1958 donc ils se connaissent de longue
date ils sont un peu moins proches
puisque Alain Delon depuis 2 3 ans ne
répond plus à Brigitte bardau quand lui
envoie des messages mais leur amitier
est resté elle a dit quoi alors elle est
extrêmement remontée elle dit c'est
lamentable de médiocrité de salire
l'image d'Alain voilà elle elle veut
qu'alindelon reste l'icône tel qu'il a
été un peu comme elle he qui s'est
retranché dans son splendide isolement
qu'il avait dit même d'ailleurs quand
estfin quand on pouvait encore le bah il
disait je n'ai pas envie qu'on me voit à
partir du moment où je serai dégradé je
me retirerai à douchi d'ailleurs il
voulait il disait qu'il voulait finir
ses jours à douchi et je me retirerai à
douchi je retirerai je me retirerai pour
qu'on garde l'image de moi je me
retirerai mais nous a fa je me retirer
mais donc du coup c'est fills il
respecte pas cette
envie c filles qui ne respectent pas
puisque c'est eu qui on v MRE enureette
histoire ave l'ticle de par match c'est
ça l'élément déclencheur c'est l'ticle
de Paris Match en fait il ne respectent
pas ce que que c'est qui ne respecte pas
les volontés de
son et elle elle veut l'emmener ailleurs
j'ai bien compris mais elle elle ne fait
que répondre à
finalement la première pierre de toute
cette histoire c'est l'article de Paris
Match je trouv que c'était très
intéressant ce disait Jean-Michel par
faitette hisire nous passionne parce
qu'on n pas concerné par les millions
d'alins Delon en fait elle nous renvoie
tous à ce qu'on fait dans les fins de
vie de nos parents de nos grands-parents
de nos aînés de la dépendance de
décision final est-ce que ces décisions
là il faut les prendre en amont quand on
est en forme et quand on est encore
lucide plutô que quand on est grabataire
dans un lit quand on a pas toute sa tête
et tout son discernement parce que
finalement peut-être que lui il sait
même plus ce qu'il veut et on ne sait
pas il s'agit pas de parler de lui mais
en fait je trouve qu'on est tous
concernés par ça effet miroir non a
raison même s'il y a 5000 € 10000 € en
jeu une maison famill déchire comm comm
de long alors évidemment là c'est on
parle de 300 millions mais le parcours
de fin c'est vrai qu' faut se poser des
questions parce que ça fout la merde
dans toutes les familles dès qu'il y a
un petit peu d'argent c'est terminé ça
fout un bordel pas possible vu tuas vu
comme ça ça fout ça fout le fichoir non
mais je pense que sœ Catherine est
content de vivre en marge quand elle
entend ça qu voyez tout ça surœ
Catherine franchement dites
quoi vous êtes bien êes
tranquille vous êtes au compte de tout
tout ce dont on a parlé ou pas du tout
bon j'ai pas trop suivi j'avoue
je suis plus ce qui se passe dans les
cités mais mais ça me parle beaucoup ce
que vous dites ce que vous venez de dire
en fait euh et et en effet pourquoi la
presse a fait voler en éclat un truc
quelque chose qui est interne mais en
même temps c'est des décisions qui sont
fondamental de vie en fait là on parle
de question de vie de personne et je
pense que cette décision elle est c'est
c'est à la personne de exaement son
intériorité de de de de le chercher de
c'est compliqué c'est des questions qui
sont hyper compqu des familles qui se
déchirent on en a partout partout
partout dans tous les milieux sociaux et
dans tous les désol elle vit pas en
marge elle vit en
Corse pas comprismission l'émission qui
est en
Corion mécr
plus vie éta en banlieu
parisien
[Applaudissements]
ce sms qu'on m' envoyé alors ce serait
une conversation entre anouchka Delon et
Anthony Delon c'est un sms exclusif qui
va être posté sur les réseaux donc voilà
ils m'ont dit de le lire avant et qu'il
le posterait après voilà alors c'est sur
l'affaire bien entendu Alain Dolo je
crois qu'ils l'ont en régie voilà si
vous pouviez le mettre les chér on va le
lire ensemble voilà alors c'est Anouka
qui s'adresse à Anthony dellon alors
arrêtez la Chimo qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dis dis je vais
rentrer avant et on voit le reste sur
place on discutera sur place Al la
Fabien j'ai toutes les infos je suis
parti depuis une semaine je pars il
allait bien et là je suis ici à vous
entendre c'est de la merde donc je
rentre en attendant arrêter la chimio
préviens glaçon c'est le voilà c'est
c'est le médecin c'est bien on fait
partir la japonaise et il se dégrade on
va avoir l'air bien s'il lui arrive
quelque chose ça aussi il faut que ça
rentre donc je vais rentrer et pour le
reste on voit là-bas je rentre alors
c'est un sms que je découvre avec vous
Gilles qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire en
fait alors glaçon pour vous avez cé
glaçon c'est le médecin suisse donc qui
dirige l'ensemble des donc là c'est y a
ce SMS qui vont sortir là sur les
réseaux sociaux donc ça c'est émis par
Anouchka exactement Antony voilà oui euh
bah là je suis parti depuis une semaine
c'està-dire c'est très significatif je
pars il allait bien et là je suis ici à
vous entendre c'est la merde donc je
rentre c'est-à-dire que Anouchka ça
corrobore tout ce qu'elle a dit jusque-
là mais avec plus de force c'est-à-dire
que quand elle n'est pas là et bien il y
a plus de trait pour son père elle est
pas là arrêter la chimio c'est-à-dire
que il y a une sorte de fatalité de la
part d'anouka qui dit en gros que ses
frères ne poursuivent pas le traitement
et elle elle dit voilà je vais rentrer
parce que c'est ce que elle nous
confirmait elle est en Suisse et elle
voit que le traitement pour son père est
arrêté et donc elle est obligée de
rentrer voilà ça ça confirme vous le
prenez comme ça vous est-ce que vous
avez une autre interprétation tableal
exactement la même chose que que G qui a
deux visions différentes en fait parce
que ça ça va être mis à mon avis par par
Anthony ou je sais pas par quiê d'accord
pour qu'on arrête le traitement aussi il
y a une partie qui veut pas
d'acharnement thérapeutique et une
partie qui veut absolument enfin on a
l'impression qu' sont les deux sincères
en fait les deuxamp sont sincères
ENIT en fait unecion pour le pè de
volent du bien à leur père mais sur on
sa pas quel est le bien que veut lui
alinon pour luime fait imaginer on peut
imaginer au vu de ce que dit Anouka que
finalement les garçons l'ont convaincu
puisquelle dit alors arrêtez la chimio
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise c'est vrai là en tout cas moi ce
que je retiens de de cet échange c'est
que j'ai l'impression que les garçons
voilà voilà là je me dis ils ont envie
que leur père ils ont envie de prendre
une décision pour leur faire parce qu'il
le voi souffrir et que Anouchka veut
j'ai l'impression de se battre jusqu'au
bout plus qu' alin fabien est tout le
temps dans la maison va pas il est avec
lui c'est lui qui le bordi qui le couche
merci à mais bu voudrais il faudrait que
vous vieniez lundi pour nous parler
d'une autre affaire